citizens of the reject Nation Greg here
today so thank you for clicking on this
video first off
um secondly we got to see werewolf by
night early we of course shot a reaction
to it we can't edit that or put it up
until of course it's out on Disney plus
but I wanted to help contribute to the
word of mouth that's been going around
because we did get to see it before the
social media embargo lifted and social
media bargain was the only thing that's
lifted right now so we do got to keep
the thoughts here really short
um pretty much like what would I say in
a Twitter thread and here's what I think
I would say in a Twitter thread uh it is
awesome it honors the universal monster
horror Vibe something that I absolutely
love I've talked extensively about it
and I really feel like it's captured
truly here it commits fully to its tone
its style its Aesthetics the the lead
characters are great it's a little more
violent than I expected it to be there
were times I was like wow that's
actually probably it's really violent
it's not like terrifying in the same
sense of how those classic monster
movies were not terrifying uh it leans
more into uh its Soul than just the
horror but there is definitely horror
there again I don't want to say too much
but I'll end it off with this we all
thought that it was easily one of the
best things out of Marvel phase four
like easily
and it might be one of the best things
out of the MCU it's certainly one of the
most unique refreshing and it's it's
just nice to have something that
genuinely feels
inspiring uh to have a direction like
this so yeah guys I I cannot wait for
you guys to hey see our reaction that's
the most important thing uh but B for
you guys just to experience this special
watch it with the lights off now like
how we did it but watch it with the
lights off and really get the full
immersive experience
um yeah well worth it for sure
[Music]